the BMW 3 Series has a new edition a
Gran Turismo the 3-series GT combines
the sporty dynamism of a sedan with a
versatility of its touring station wagon
the main difference however is the
fastback hatch with an adjustable
spoiler the car is also bigger the eight
centimeters of extra height allows the
driver to sit six centimeters higher
geometry Karim Habib from BMW explains
that the engineers discussed the
proportions at great length and he
believes this is evident in the coop a
like silhouette and of course the width
height and length with dupatta de
lehenga the GT is 20 centimeters longer
than the turing the front is typical
3-series the lights and grill blend into
one another the sporty feel is clear
from the roof line and hatch I'm gets
fine there are two innovations explains
kohima be an air curtain at the front
and behind the front wheel this an
air-breather they both improve the
aerodynamics by reducing turbulence in
the wheel arch the air breather reduces
the pressure in the wheel arch making
the car more aerodynamic as well as
reducing emissions and fuel consumption
dynamic when attorneys done vinegar in
mattoon in vinegar football there are
three gasoline and two fuel efficient
diesel engines an offer for the 3-series
GT
LMO to endorse keller from BMW says all
engines come with the latest TwinPower
Turbo technology that means the engines
are designed to create maximum driving
pleasure but fuel consumption and the
latest emission requirements are also
taken into account he explains that the
technology onboard enables a very
economical driving experience Varnado we
tested the 320d GT with an output of 135
kilowatts and a maximum torque of 380
newton meters the car goes from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour in 7.9 seconds that's
only 0.2 seconds slower than the
comparable station wagon and that's
despite being 65 kilos heavier and
having a higher drag coefficient
furthermore patient horse killer tells
us that diesel engines are very
important for the European market they
provide great driving pleasure with high
torque and agility yet are very
fuel-efficient he predicts the 320d will
be the car that sells best it has a top
speed of 230 kilometers an hour and a
fuel consumption of 4.9 litres per 100
kilometers annoyingly fell from the
kilometer but what do the critics think
of a new GT we asked Australian auto
journalists Greg Kable to give us his
first impressions
what we have here is the third variant
of the three series it's a car which is
both sporty and at the same time
practical lots of room inside but a very
sporty driving experience our test car
has an 8-speed automatic transmission
well what BMW has done here is make a
car which is very roomy inside thus it's
the seat position here is a little bit
higher than in the 3 series sedan and
the 3 series touring and in the rear you
have a lot more legroom 7 centimeters
more to be precise and that extra leg
room in the 3-series GT means it's a lot
more pleasant on long journeys the 3
Series Touring has traditionally being
very popular in Europe that in countries
like America and China not so popular so
what BMW has done is has made a
so-called liftback body style and
they're hoping that this car will appeal
to Americans and the Chinese but it's
not just the design that is different
there are also new functions screens
that keep prying eyes away from the
trunk can easily be detached and stored
the standard GT has 40 liters more cargo
space than the station wagon the rear
seat row can easily be folded down to
create more trunk space BMW hopes this
will all help to make it popular
overseas
small and agile and expensive to buy and
to operate the city go is the smallest
member of the Skoda family and with no
optional equipment costs 8890 euros in
Germany it's a close relative of the VW
up and the sea at me but are these city
compacts only four purest drivers we
wanted to find out what the little check
can do the first thing we notice was
it's good shark absorbance it ironed out
bumps smoothly which we didn't expect in
the compact lead
you
thanks to its nine meters 80 turning
radius the Skoda Citigo is easy to
maneuver in town and parking garages and
in narrow crooked alleyways with the
exception of the entry-level model all
city goes have power steering the city
goes standard safety features include
four airbags an electronic stability
program an anti-lock brake system and an
electronic differential lock the city
safe drive breaking assistant is
optional at speeds below 30 km/h it uses
a laser sensor to recognize any danger
of collision beginner drivers will love
the hill start assistant which is
standard equipment it keeps the car from
rolling backwards when the brakes are
released
the interior shows how big a small car
can see the comfortably shaped front
seats with integrated headrests do more
than look sporty they offer even big
people enough room and good lateral
support this is the first time a Skoda
has provided side airbags to give the
driver and front seat passenger head and
chest protection
and the steering wheels height can be
individually adjusted to fit a tall or
short driver if you want electric window
openers you need the variant with extras
which also comes with infotainment and
navigation systems
the city go provides plenty of storage
space a bottle holder in the middle
console and nets on the sides of the
backrests the city go is also available
as a four-door hatchback in the two-door
version a flick of a weber provides easy
access to the back seat which has plenty
of amenities too but it's a bit skimpy
with legroom but the trunks 251 liters
of cargo space is considerable in this
class of vehicle the back seats can be
turned down to increase that to more
than 950 litres hooks on the sides of
the trunk can be used to fix a bags we
tested the version with a more powerful
55 kilowatt gasoline engine it takes 13
point two seconds to accelerate to 100
kilometres an hour the price for this
model is twelve thousand four hundred
fifteen euros in Germany a five gear
manual transmission is standard but
automatic is available as well our
judgement in summary the Skoda Citigo is
wonderfully uncomplicated it's easy
handling makes it worth checking out not
only for beginners but also for practice
and older drivers
with the track Chevrolet now has a
compact SUV on offer strikingly shaped
wheel wells and muscular flanks
characterized the four point 25 meter
long tracks the line of the roof tapers
toward the back and ends in an
integrated roof spoiler the tracks comes
in to gasoline and one diesel variant
other options include a sixth gear
automatic transmission and an adaptive
all-wheel system AMG presents the sls
AMG coupe a black series inspired by the
race car version the sls AMG gt3 the
Black Series is distinguished above all
by its lightweight construction the 464
kilowatt v8 engine takes the coop a
black from zero to 100 in just 3.6
seconds top speed is 315 kilometers an
hour vehicle costs about two hundred
fifty thousand euros in Germany
it looks like a Ferrari but hails from
rural Bavaria the glass GT enthusiast
uba Guzan owns two of these rare
vehicles the 1700 GT coupe a and the
1300 GT convertible since his youth he's
been a fan of the sporty models created
by car developer Hans glass goossen says
he really likes cars by glass especially
this 1300 GT here it was introduced in
1963 in goose and says even as a young
boy he was thrilled by its great shape
and high performance and he still is
today the convertibles 1.3 liter engine
produces 85 horsepower goosen tells us
that half a century ago glass was a
small company operating in lower bavaria
and a handful of technicians were
involved in making cars like this he
thinks it was a great feat for the time
side funding I mosaic was a licensee da
gama thoughtless it's Italian designed
powerful engine and sporty suspension
could have made the glass GT into a
best-seller but its humble lineage put
the brakes on any dreams of grand or
aunts glass produced farm machinery
before moving on to scooters and small
cars like the Go Go mobile the glass GT
could never quite shake its rural roots
of agusan tells us that the car was
presented at the frankfurt motor show in
1963 the body was produced in italy by
pietro fluo and then assembled in
bavaria sasanka boat he notes that the
bumpers of the front had to be fitted
individually as do the doors because the
body was essentially custom made for
each car I know I said fatty going funky
didn't bargain when that's why the doors
and the bumpers were numbered stunning
ocean really likes the cars lines
especially the sloping curve at the rear
he thinks it gives the car a sporty
flair and the two tail lights on either
side highlight it's Italian style in
Italian steve is on the scooter I was
playing
the glass GT looks fast and goes like
the wind in the early 1960s it was one
of the few German made sports cars
around this glass GT fam loves to drive
the car in curvy country roads best
because it's so much fun he says the
1700 GT accelerates very well going from
0 to 100 kilometers an hour and around
10 seconds which was pretty good for its
time the cars top speed is 186
kilometers an hour which he feels is
pretty amazing for a car built in
nineteen sixty-five Goosen says the car
has a very special engine a four
cylinder with a timing belt drive and
overhead cams the timing belt drive was
first used in a glass Oh for in 1961 and
he says it was the first series
production engine to use this drive
mechanism his monthly PHP
the GT is not just fun to drive it's
also very reliable who've agusan used to
drive it to work every day it's a real
sports car goosen says one in which you
can feel a real connection to the road
and which takes curves very well the GT
has a sports car engine you need to warm
it up a bit and then it'll give you lots
of pleasure as if you why did I buy
that's why it that was the GT coupe a
dilution says and now he shows us
something really special the glass JT
1300 convertible just three hundred
sixty three of them were ever made
whereas five thousand of the coop a's
were produced it's a jewel of a car he
says otherwise the vehicles were
identical and both were available with
either at 1300 or 1700 engine they were
both so nice he couldn't choose between
the two so he bought both last GTS and
good conditions sell for between 20 and
30 thousand euros
Goossen says anyone wanting to purchase
a glass should really make sure the body
is in good shape as having the car
painted or sheetmetal work done is very
costly Biden since customs if you're gay
just tracking down a glass GT is a feat
in itself they're rare as the glass firm
was taken over by BMW in 1966
member